معنا من القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري
نجوان الخلافات بين اعضاء هذه الحكومه
يعني لم تعد سرا هي في العلن ولكن لعلك
تطلعين على التفاصيل هذه
الخلافات بالفعل عثمان هناك خلافات على
مستويات عده سواء كان بين القياده
العسكريه وبين القياده السياسيه في
اسرائيل لكن ليس فقط حتى داخل القياده
السياسيه هناك خلافات بشان بعض الملفات
التي تدار خلال هذه الحرب جزء منها قضيه
ملف الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه هناك اكثر من
تيار وهناك اكثر من اسلوب يتم التعامل مع
هذا الملف من خلاله سواء كان التيار الذي
يقوده رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير
دفاعه يوف جلنت وهما يقودان التيار الذي
يؤيد او يدفع باتجاه مزيد من الضغط
العسكري على حركه حماس من اجل الافراج
عن الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه في مقابل ذلك
هناك تيار بيني جانز والوزير المراقب في
مجلس الحرب جادي ايزنكوت
اللذان يطالبان بابرام صفقه تبادل وابقاء
قضيه الاسرى على راس الاولويات خلال هذه
الحرب وحتى تقديمها على القتال في غزه
ايزنكوت كان قد ابدى موقفا اكثر
ربما مغايرا موقف بيني جانز حتى بانه يجب
وقف الحرب من اجل اعاده هؤلاء ال الاسرى
لكن هناك ايضا قضيه خلافات ما بين ال
القياده العسكريه والقياده السياسيه فيما
يتعلق بتحديد وجهه اليوم التالي في غزه
قبل ايام قليله كانت هناك بعض التسريبات
عن مصادر عسكريه بدات تتحدث بشكل واضح بان
ما تصفه بالانجازات العسكريه التي حققت في
بعض المناطق في غزه تحديدا في المناطق
الشماليه بدات تتاكل بسبب عدم وجود رؤيه
واضحه للقياده السياسيه في اسرائيل عن
اليوم التالي وهي المرحله التي ستلي الحرب
على غزه وبعد انسحاب القوات من داخل غزه
او على الاقل اعاده انتشار وتموضع لهذه
القوات في مناطق مختلفه وهذا اليوم سربت
ايضا او نقلت قناه التلفزه الاسرائيليه
الثانيه ع عن مسؤولين عسكريين قولهم بانه
تم رفع ما يوصف
بالبطاقه الحمراء في وجه القياده السياسيه
للمطالبه بتحديد وجهه المستوى السياسي في
اسرائيل عما سيحدث في غزه بعد انتهاء
الحرب ومن سيتولى اداره شؤون غزه وسط
خلافات كبيره حتى في داخل مجلس الحرب حول
رؤيه اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بذلك ووسط خلافات
مع الاداره الامريكيه ايضا نتنياهو مازال
يصر بانه لا يريد اشراك السلطه الفلسطينيه
في اليوم التالي في قطاع غزه حتى على
مستوى اداره الشؤون المدنيه هناك فيما
يتخبط الجيش الاسرائيلي بكيفيه التعامل مع
الانسحابات من المناطق التي يعلن بانه تمت
السيطره عليها ناريا لكنه بدا يرصد وفقا
ايضا لتسريبات نقلتها صحيفه هارتس عوده
حركه حماس من
اجل العمل في هذه المواقع ويقولون بان هذا
الفراغ الذي بدا يظهر في المناطق التي سحب
منها الجيش قواته سيمكن حركه حماس من
العوده والعمل وكانت هناك عمليات رصد
نقلتها هارس بان حركه حماس عادت لتعين حتى
رؤساء للكتائب
ايه العسكريه بعد ان اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه قام بتفكيك هذه الاطر
العسكريه وحاليا يحارب ما وصفها بالجيوب
العسكريه لحركات المقاومه دعني فقط اختم
عثمان بانه قبل قليل فقط زار نتنياهو فرقه
غزه العسكريه في المناطق الجنوبيه بمناسبه
ما يعرف في اسرائيل هذا اليوم عيد غرس
الاشجار قام بالمشاركه في غرس الاشجار
لكنه مجددا كرر نفس التصريحات التي يكررها
دائما بشان ان اسرائيل ستواصل هذه الحرب
حتى تحقيق
النصر الم
وهو يتمثل بالقضاء على حركه حماس واعاده
المحتجزين في غزه شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان
نجوان سمري من القدس